[Music]
we have used what is essentially a
children's toy basically silly putty and
we've added a very very small amount of
graphene to give a compass
material with with useful sensing
properties when you took the composite
the silly putty or graphene in it and
you squashed it or deformed it in any
way its electrical resistance would
change dramatically the electrical
resistance change for a normal strain
sensor would be there's a sensitivity
factor which is 2 and 2 is good two is
fine flood of applications are sensors
at sensitivity factors of up to 500 so
we knew immediately that we had
something interesting there are actually
really important applications based on
this so for example if you take the
composite and you mounted on the chest
cavity of a person it will the
resistance of the compasses will change
as they breathe as their chest expands
and contracts so you can measure
breathing and actually that's important
in areas in in medical diagnostics for
example encaustic caught death or in
certain conditions like sleep apnea and
you can measure them by measuring
breathing but there's a much more
important application we feel and that's
monitoring a pulse
so pulse is known to be a wellness
indicator if you're ill your pulse will
change so we found that when the the
center is held up here to the carotid
artery that that pulsing of that are
free can actually be detected and can be
read out in an electrical resistance
change so we can measure the pulse which
gives a measure of the heart rate but
the sensor is sensitive enough that we
can also get the blood pressure out of
that and that's actually quite important
we can measure blood pressure of course
we can but it's not straightforward to
measure it continuously and that's what
this sensor can do so we believe that
there will be a lot of applications in
medical devices and result in diagnostic
and so it really shows the power of
nanomaterials a small amount of nano can
really turn the ordinary into something
extraordinary
[Music]
[Music]